Was steht wieder?
Guten Tag Herr Doktor.
Guten Tag, er ist mein Name.
Und ich bin der Diensthabender Arzt auf diese Station und werde mit Ihnen Aufnahme gesprächführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja gerne Herr Doktor, wenn Sie mir helfen bin ich sehr froh.
Ja natürlich, ich bin da für Sie. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Hans Zimmer.
Hans Zimmer?
Ja.
Okay. Und wie heißen Sie Herr Zimmer?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
54.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
1. Februar 1968.
68.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie Herr Zimmer?
Ich bin so ungefähr 1.80, jetzt aktuell 1.78 kann man sagen.
1.78, okay.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Also ich habe abgenommen, aber ich wiege jetzt noch 105 Kilogramm.
105 Kilogramm.
Aber ich habe 10 Kilogramm abgenommen, Herr Doktor, in den letzten Monaten.
Das war ungewollt, oder?
Ja, ungewollt.
10 Kilogramm abgenommen.
Ja.
Okay.
Herr Zimmer.
Und wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden außer diese Abnahmen?
Herr Doktor, wie Sie sehen können, kann ich kaum laufen.
Also ich schaffe nur noch den Weg von hier,
von dem Stuhl zur Tür, zur Tür.
Und auch zu Hause, kann ich nur noch zur Toilette laufen.
Mehr schaffe ich nicht.
Ich habe mich auch gebaut.
Und vielleicht fange ich mal an damit, wie es angefangen hat.
Also ich habe jetzt vor ungefähr 2, 3 Monaten Corona Infektion gehabt.
Das war jetzt nicht schon die zweite Corona Infektion, die ich hatte.
Und war da halt entsprechend schwach.
Hatte auch Fieber gehabt damals.
Und so Grippe Symptome, die jetzt ein, 2 Wochen angehalten haben.
Aber dann wurde es nicht besser.
Und ich habe mich dann den nächsten Wochen auch noch sehr schwach gefühlt.
Und hab dann auch gemerkt, dass ich weniger Appetit habe.
Nichts mehr essen konnte.
Und ich habe auch Beschwerden mit dem Bauch bekommen.
Und zwar ist es jetzt in den letzten 1, 2 Wochen mir aufgefallen.
Mein Bauch ist dick, aber meine Arme, meine Muskeln sind ganz dünn geworden.
Also ich habe viel Muskel verloren.
Und haben mein Bauch aber dick.
Und wie gesagt, ich habe ungefähr 15 Kilo abgenommen.
Jetzt in den letzten Wochen nicht mehr so stark.
15 Kilo.
10 bis 15 ungefähr.
Ich hatte mal 120, 115, 120 gehabt.
Haben Sie Bewegungsanschränkungen oder wegen der Medikative?
Seit 1, 2 Wochen kann ich mich jetzt nicht mehr, kann ich nicht mehr laufen.
Also ich bin ganz schwach geworden.
Aber Sie haben keine Schmerzen an Beinen oder Gehlechen?
Meine Beine sind schlank und tun auch nicht weh.
Wo ich Schmerzen habe, das kann ich Ihnen auch sagen.
Wenn ich tief atme, tut es auf der rechten Seite hier unten an den Rippen weh.
Okay, beim Atmen.
Ja, und meine Frau sagt auch, ich atme nicht mehr gut, sagt sie.
Ich atme es schnell.
Haben Sie Atmen oder?
Also ich merke das nicht so sehr, aber sie sagt, ich hätte Atemnot.
Aber ich bewege mich nicht.
Deswegen merke ich das nicht so.
Ja, okay.
Wussten Sie auch?
Eigentlich nicht.
Da habe ich mal bei Corona gehust, aber jetzt nicht mehr seit vielen Wochen.
Okay.
Müssen Sie erhöhte Schlafen?
Zum Beispiel, wie viele Kissen nützen Sie beim Schlafen, Herr Zimmer?
Ja, ich muss mit Kissen schlafen, weil wenn ich mich flach lege,
dann drückt der Bauch und dann kriege ich keinen Luft.
Sie müssen mindestens zwei Kissen nutzen, oder?
Ja, okay.
Herr Zimmer, haben Sie Herzrasen?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, wenn ich nicht sage.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Farbeveränderungen auf der Haut bemerkt,
besonders auf Bauchbereich oder in den Händen?
Kann ich jetzt so nicht sagen, Herr Doktor.
Ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Okay.
Haben Sie keinen Schmerz im Bauchbereich?
Ja, also ich habe auch den Hausarzt gefragt,
weil ich habe schon Schmerz, ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel gesagt,
aber es ist spannend und drückt.
Deswegen hat er mir Novalgientropfen gegeben, dann nehme ich ein.
Dann hilft es mal.
Ich nehme nur zweimal pro Tag Novalgientropfen ein, 40 Stück.
Dann hilft es bis, aber es ist nicht gut.
Ich trage Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Spalle.
Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie keinen Schmerz inszenen,
ist es wirklich unter Baucherschmerzen.
Wo will Sie dann sehr einordnen auf diese Schmerzspalle?
Ich würde sagen, ich kann nicht sagen, dass es richtig Schmerzen sind.
Ich würde sagen, so 1, 2 vielleicht.
Also richtig Schmerzen sind es auch nicht.
Das ist eher unwohl sein im Bauch.
Okay.
Herr Zimmer, haben Sie irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Ja, habe ich ja, Doktor.
Das kann ich sagen, ich habe eine chronische Hepatitis B-Infektion.
Die wird auch mit Medikamenten behandelt seit längerer Zeit.
Und da gab es auch mal den Verdacht auf einen Tumor in der Leber.
Das hat sich aber nicht bestätigt,
die regelmäßig kontrolliert so einmal in einem Jahr.
Was für ein Tumor, Böseartige oder Böteartikel, wie Sie das sehen?
Die hatten den Verdacht gehabt, aber dann haben sie MRT gemacht.
Das hat sich aber nicht bestätigt.
Die sagen, die Leber ist ein bisschen kaputt bei mir durch diese Hepatitis Infektion.
Und da kann man manchmal nicht entscheiden, ob es Böseartige Knoten sind
oder manchmal gutartige Knoten.
Und das haben Sie jetzt erst mal gesagt, muss man nur beobachten.
Okay.
Hat jemand an Schwumpfleber gesprochen?
Ich habe es nicht verstanden nochmal, bitte.
Schwumpfleber.
Das ist nicht gesagt worden, also Sie haben gesagt, so eine Art Zirose könnte das sein.
Ja, das meinte ich, genau.
Zirose meinte ich.
Ja, das Wort ist mal gefallen bei den Gesprächen.
Ja, okay.
War Ihre letzte Untersuchung bei den Hausarzt oder beim internationalen Arzt?
Ja, es war in der Klinik gewesen, das war ungefähr ein halben Jahr.
Wie war denn befreund?
Ja, die haben gesagt, man muss weiter beobachten.
Das ist nichts Sicheres.
Okay.
Ja, jetzt immer, fühlen Sie sich febri?
Also, das ist nicht mehr.
Also bei Corona hatte ich Fieber gehabt, aber jetzt habe ich keinen Fieber.
Aber ich schwitze schon sehr stark auch nachts.
Ja, aber man sieht nachts, ich weiß.
Aber kein Fieber.
Ich habe nicht gemerkt, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ja, also der Stuhlgang ist unregelmäßig jetzt, muss man sagen,
weil ich da auch nichts mehr esse.
Und Wasserlassen ist auch, ich trinke nicht mehr viel,
weil einfach, wenn ich trinke, ich muss dann auch Gefühl haben,
dass ich erbrechen muss, so dass der Urin schon etwas konzentrierter ist,
glaube ich.
Wie oft müssen Sie erbrechen?
Taglich erbrechen Sie?
Fast täglich.
Es gibt auch mal Tage, wo es nicht erbrechen, aber fast täglich.
Okay.
Wie sieht das Bruch aus?
Also ist auch mal Gallik.
Gelblich grün, ich war auch schon mal.
Okay.
Wie ernähren Sie sich, Herr Zimmer?
Können Sie alle vertragen?
Also ich esse jetzt fast nichts mehr und ich habe auch jetzt
aus Bekanntenkreis gehört, dass ich wenig Zucker essen soll.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt fast Kaganakolientrate gegessen.
Hab darauf geachtet.
Aber ich esse sehr wenig nur noch.
Entschuldigung, Herr Zimmer, ich konnte Augustik nicht verstanden.
Haben Sie Stuhlkrankheit oder?
Nein, aber die haben empfohlen, ich soll weniger Zucker essen
und ich habe keine Ernährung.
Also wenig Kohlhydrate oder keine Kohlhydrate.
Aber das ist Ihre selber Entschuldigung.
Das war kein therapeutischer Maßnahme.
Nein, das habe ich von Bekannten gehört.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Herr Zimmer, nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente regelmäßig ein?
Ja, ich habe ein Lister mitgenommen.
Ich habe auch eine Schildtröße unter Funktionen.
Deshalb habe ich einen Eltroxin 75,
einen morgens früh auf Nüchtern wagen.
75 Mikrogramm.
Morgens vor dem Frühstück.
Seit wann haben Sie Schildtröße unter Funktionen?
Ja, das ist ungefähr ein paar Jahre, drei, vier Jahre,
nämlich das Medikament schon.
Dann habe ich Bluthochdruck,
dann nehme ich auch Medikamente eines Rami-Pri,
ich finde nicht Medikament.
Morgens, oder?
Morgens, ja.
Und das noch was?
Ja, dann hat der Hausarzt mir aufgeschrieben,
weil ich Vitamin D-Mangel habe, Decrystol, 20.000,
einmal pro Woche, nämlich das.
Ja.
Und dann hat er mir aufgeschrieben für diese Bauchbeschwerden
Pantoprazol, das nehme ich eins, auch morgens.
Morgens, wie viele Milliganzen nehmen Sie?
Das ist 40er, Pantoprazol 40.
40, okay.
Und dann nehme ich wegen der Medikamente,
die Pantoprazol, die Pantoprazol,
und dann nehme ich wegen der Schmerzen noch das Novalgin eintropfen,
ungefähr zweimal pro Tag 40 Tropfen nehme ich ein.
Okay.
Und dann hat er mir noch aufgeschrieben,
wenn das nicht ausreicht mit Novalgin,
soll ich ein anderer Tablet noch zusätzlich nehmen,
Tramadol, heißt das, Tramadol rettat.
Tramadol nehmen, okay.
100 Milligramm.
Und für die Hepatitis nämlich das Teno-4-Vir.
Teno-4-Vir, okay.
Milligramm und Posierung?
Das habe ich jetzt nicht, eine Tablette pro Tag.
Ich glaube, 245, glaube ich, war das gesehen.
Okay, morgens nehmen Sie, oder?
Mittags.
Okay.
Okay, herzlichen Dank.
Das war es, oder?
Das sind die Medikamente ja, richtig.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert, herzlichen Dank.
Nein.
Ich hatte keine Operation.
Ja, ich rauche aber nicht so viel.
Ich habe auch mal aufgehört und wieder angefangen.
Also aktuell rauche ich durchschnittlich.
Bitte.
Durchschnittlich.
Ungefähr 10 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Okay.
Seit wann?
Also ich habe gesagt, wie gesagt,
als Jugendlicher angefangen mit so 18 Jahren,
aber habe dann zwischendurch auch mal einige Jahre nicht geraucht.
Dann wieder angefangen.
Also wenn ich das alles zusammenfasse, würde ich sagen.
Ja, so vielleicht 25 Jahre habe ich geraucht.
Bisher.
Ja, verstehe.
Okay.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, Alkohol trinkt gar nicht.
Wegen der Liebstergerichte haben die Ärzte gesagt,
ich soll keine Alkohol trinken.
Sind Sie schon immer nicht alkoholiker, oder?
Also ich habe früher auch nie Alkohol getrunken, richtig.
Okay, super.
Und herzlichen Dank.
Wie grünen Sie allergisch auf irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ist nichts bekannt. Nein.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Covid-19 hatten vor 3 Monaten.
Ungefähr, ja.
Wie haben Sie ungefähr 3 Monate?
Und sind Sie gegen die Corona geimpft?
Ja, bin ich auch.
Die letzte Impfung war also ungefähr Januar gewesen.
Und auch gegen Kinderkrankheiten sind sie vorständig geheim.
Das weiß ich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Okay, das ganz gut.
Jetzt stelle ich Ihnen eine Routine Frage.
Bitte nehmen Sie das nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie schon mal mit Drogenerfahrung?
Nein, habe noch nie Drogen genommen.
Ja, super.
Ja, jetzt mal.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern sind schon gestorben.
Die hatten auch verschiedene Krankheiten.
Bei uns in der ganzen Familie haben alle Haptitis B leider.
Also meine Geschwister haben auch Haptitis B, weil Eltern auch.
Mein Vater ist an einer anderen Krankheit gestorben.
Also die Prostatakrebs.
Prostatakrebs.
Die Mutter hatte Herzprobleme.
Ich weiß noch nicht genau, was.
Okay.
Herzhymne war zu Sie gestorben.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Herzhymne?
Ja, ich habe ja.
Und?
Also ich habe zwei Schwestern und noch drei Brüder.
Alle Leute unter Hepatitis.
Ja, die haben Hepatitis.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich herzumachen?
Ich bin selbstständig.
Ich bin im Einzelhandel.
Ich mache so Elektrogeräte verkaufen.
Elektrogeräte verkaufen?
Elektrogeräte.
Selbstständig, ja.
Sind Sie sofrieden mit der Arbeit?
Ja.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Belastungen bei der Arbeit?
Besonders Stärkebeleistung?
Normalerweise nein, nicht so.
Wow, okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei Kinder.
Drei Kinder, gut.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja.
Oder haben Sie auch Hepatitis?
Nein, die haben keine Hepatitis bekommen.
Ich habe schon meine wichtige Frage gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja.
Oder haben wir etwas vergessen?
Ich glaube, das Wichtigste haben Sie gefragt.
Ich will nur, dass Sie mir helfen,
dass diese Beschwerden nachlassen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie Sie mir helfen können.
Ob es mir Medikamente geben können.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist eine sehr wichtige Frage.
Ich möchte Sie sagen,
dass es eine Menge Medikamente geben können.
Ja, ich werde über Ihre Erkrankung
ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Dadurch können wir bereits wichtige Rückschülse
auf Ihre Erkrankungen sehen.
Aber erst müssen Sie ein bisschen gedulden.
Ja, im Wartezimmer.
Und werde ich
zu Ihnen gleichkommen.
Und danach werde ich
andere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ja.
Haben Sie noch irgendwelche Quarzt?
Muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Oder was meinen Sie, Doktor?
Ja, das sieht so aus.
Wahrscheinlich bleiben Sie bei uns.
Und was machen Sie heute mit mir alles?
Was ist die Situation geblieben?
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Was machen Sie heute mit mir alles?
Was ist die Situation geplant?
Ja, so erst werde Sie körperlich
ausführlich untersuchen
und dann Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ihre Laborwerte
und Blutbilderwerbe,
Nährwerte,
Untersuchen.
Und wahrscheinlich haben Sie Wasser
anzammeln in Bauchhöhlen.
Deswegen müssen wir
Flüssigkeitprobe entnehmen
und untersuchen.
Wie machen Sie das?
Das ist ein klein Peaks.
Das werden wir mit Nadel.
Bei dieser Untersuchung
müssen wir auch Ultraschall durchführen.
Mit Hilfe von Ultraschall
werden wir diese Untersuchung durchführen.
Stechen Sie Nadel in den Bauch?
Ja, genau.
Bei dieser Untersuchung
kann es Blutungen kommen.
Aber das wird nicht so schlimm.
Sie sind natürlich im Krankenhaus.
Wenn etwas passieren,
können wir gleich sofortige Maßnahmen
erreicheln.
Es gibt keine Alternative ohne Peaks,
dass man das nicht mehr kann.
Diese Flüssigkeit
kann man mit Hilfe von
Probeentnahme untersuchen.
Vielen Dank für die Auskunft.
Gibt es weitere Fragen
von den Zuhörern?
Was hätten Sie noch gefreut?
Was haben Sie mit der Untersuchung?
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Was haben Sie mit den Zuhörern oder
Kommentaren gefragt?
Was werden Sie wissen?
Eine Sache,
die zu Assidis führen kann.
Fällt Ihnen da was ein?
Was kann man erzählen?
Was dazu führt, dass Assidis entsteht?
Leber Zeros haben wir gesagt.
Was noch?
Sie machen aber
andere Ideen.
Ein paar Male hatte Zuschlang.
Er hatte Muskeln verloren.
Man cante Ideen.
Man hat Frisuren.
Der P陽 konsumiert keine Hydrate.
Das kann ein Auslöser sein.
Das hatten Sie gemeint, oder?
Manutrition.
Was für eine?
Manutrition kann sein, genau.
Was ist sozusagen der Kernpunkt der Manutrition, ist im Chat gerade genannt worden,
was passiert bei der Manutrition?
Bei Kindern in Afrika, haben Assetis.
Warum haben die Assetis?
Warum haben die Kinder in Afrika Assetis?
Ja, wegen einerseitiger Ernährung.
Jungsweise auch Hypohypohalbuminemangel.
Also Albuminemangel, ja, meistens auch.
Richtig.
Albuminemangel kann sein, das kann verschiedene Ursachen haben.
Entweder wenig Aufnahmen, Manutrition oder vermehrte Ausstattung,
wie zum Beispiel bei der frottischen Symptome oder Nierenprobleme.
Kann sein.
Was gibt es noch für Ursachen für Assetis?
Außerdem genannt.
Für jüngere Leute kann Assetis wie Prose sein,
aber in diesem Alter weiß ich nicht.
Ob das ein Ausgesehen ist.
Wahrscheinlich ja, richtig.
Was gibt es noch für Assetis?
Ich gucke mal im Chat, ob was geschrieben worden ist.
Pulmonellödem, ne, ne, vollständig dröhnbar.
Portal, Peretonitis, ja, ist richtig.
Also zum Beispiel, Peretonitis kann auch Assetis machen, richtig, ja.
Aber ohne Fieber kann es sein?
Ja, unwahrscheinlich, aber wir wissen ja,
mit diesen kann man nie was, nicht 100% ausschließen, ja.
Aber es wäre eine Infratialdiagnose, ein bisschen was an der Ursache.
Aber ich möchte gerne auch mal diesen hoher Portal-Druck,
erhöhter Ford-Adder-Druck.
Wie kommt das zu Stahnden?
Da, ich bin da, komm, ich bin da, ich bin da, ich bin da.
Gerne noch mal. Gerne noch mal.
Hier vorne.
Ford-Adder-Hochdruck kann entstehen durch, zum Beispiel, Leber-Zirrosia.
Und da gibt es aber noch einen anderen Faktor für Ford-Adder-Hochdruck.
Was die Ford-Adder-Ses betrifft, fährt ihnen da was ein dazu, was passiert.
Das hat der Patient gehabt, den ich vorstelle.
Volles Tase, nicht über die...
Er hat die Apathitis.
Er hat die Apathitis, dadurch auch Zirrose.
Das macht zwar, Ford-Adder-Hochdruck kann machen,
aber da gibt es noch eine andere Ursache für Ford-Adder-Hochdruck.
Ancreatitis.
Kann sein.
Aber was macht die Panker-Addis dann?
Die macht nicht direkt Ford-Adder-Hochdruck, das kann passieren.
Trombose.
Ford-Adder-Trombose, richtig.
Das hat der Patient gehabt.
Ford-Adder-Trombose, okay.
Und bei Covid weiß man nicht.
Da ist ja so, beim Vermut, dass eine Vermette
Hypercoagulabilität entstehen kann.
Das ist ja bei Covid diskutiert.
Deswegen habe ich den Patienten...
Man muss bestimmen, ja.
Aber der hat eine Ford-Adder-Trombose gehabt.
Deswegen hat er Acidis entwickelt, massiv.
Das weiß die Diagnose von den Patienten,
aber die Differenz-Jagd-Diagnosen haben wir ja letztens aufgezählt.
Gut, dann stellen Sie den Oberarzt dem Patient vor,
würde ich sagen, oder?
Ja, ich versuche.
Ja.
Okay.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit für mich?
Bitte schön, ja.
Danke.
Äh...
Ein...
Nicht so schwer als Chefars.
Eine Oberarzt, ist das schön.
Okay, herrlich.
Das ist keine Beheid, sonst.
Okay.
Ein...
54-Jährige...
...Patient Hans Zimmer...
...hat sie heute bei uns...
...wegen seit...
Entschuldigung, ich konnte nicht gut aufgeschrieben.
Seit zwei bis drei Monaten...
...aufgetretene, provokatierende, bestehende...
...Schwürdigkeiten beim Laufen und...
...Möglichkeit vorgestellt.
Körperliche Schwäche hat er überhaupt richtig.
Körperliche Schwäche.
Ja, körperliche Schwäche.
Oder Fatiqui...
Kann man sagen?
Darf man auch sagen, ja.
Aber bei diesem...
Bei diesem Fall, okay.
Bei diesem Fall körperliche Schwäche, ja.
Ja, okay.
Äh...
Der Patient...
...gab an, ihr wisst ja, Lust...
Äh...
...von 10 bis 15 Kilo innerhalb von...
...1 bis 2 Monaten.
Ja.
Das finde ich auffällig.
Das ist wichtig.
Und der Patient bemerkt, dass...
...sein Bauch dicker geworden als sonst.
Und habe er Schmerzen im Bauch.
Auf einer Skala legende Schmerzen.
Bei 1 bis 2 von 10.
Äh...
Dagegen nehmen er...
...Tramadol und Normalgintropfen.
Und ein bisschen geholfen.
Mhm.
Äh...
Außerdem berichtete der Patient...
...Äh...
...das...
Äh...
...aber Schwierigkeiten beim Einatmen.
Und...
...müße er...
...äh...
...mindestens 2 Kissen nutzen beim Schlafen.
Mhm.
Die...
...die Fragen nach Husten und Herzrasen,
...hent Rhythmusstörungen wurden beneint.
Äh...
Der Patient habe keine Farbeveränderungen auf der Haupt bemerkt.
Ich habe nicht über Gelbsducht gefragt,
aber der Patient auch berichtete nicht.
Äh...
Der Patient...
...müße...
...erbrechen fast täglich.
Äh...
Und das Brochen äh...
...sieht...
...geilig und gelblich aus.
Der Patient, leider auch unter...
Äh...
...ablitlosigkeit.
Und nachschweiz.
Äh...
...Stühlgang und Wasserlassen...
...eh...
...war...
...unafällig.
Äh...
Und...
...äh...
...wirken...
...schuldigen.
Als Vorerkrankungen...
...hab er...
...äh...
...erpathitis B.
Äh...
...und äh...
...dagegen nehmen er Tenophobia.
Äh...
...mittags.
Und vor einem...
...und anderthalb Jahren...
...äh...
...war er...
...ehm...
...seinen Hausarzt gewesen.
Und äh...
...die Untersuchung war unafällig.
Und außerdem...
...leider...
...er unter...
...hüben Protoriosi.
Dagegen nehmen er Ertroxin.
Äh... 75 Milligramm morgens.
Äh...
...und als Magenschutz...
...Tatuprosol...
...40 Milligramm nehmen er.
Äh...
...und...
...äh...
...wegen...
...vitamin Dermangel...
...nehmen er auch...
...äh...
...2.000 Einheit pro Woche.
Vitamin Depreparat.
Äh...
...äh...
...wegen...
...atoriella Hypertone...
...äh...
...nehmen er Ramitril.
Äh... 5 Milligramm morgens.
Äh...
...äh...
...die Frage äh...
...nach...
...äh...
...operation wurde verneint.
Äh...
...der Patient...
...habe auch vor...
...äh...
...zwei bis drei Monaten Corona-Infektion...
...Krankheiten.
Äh...
...estawelt äh...
...ein bis zwei Wochen symptomatisch.
Aber jetzt äh...
...hab er keine äh...
...mehr äh...
...symptome wegen äh...
...dieser Krankheiten.
An Familien an Amnesi äh...
...habe...
...äh...
...habe ich etwas gemerkt, dass ihr alle äh...
...geschwistern äh...
...leiden äh...
...an Hepatitis äh...
...Krankheit.
Äh...
...Sein Vater äh...
...sei verstorben an postatakrips äh...
...und äh...
...seine mut...
...seine Mutter äh...
...sei an äh...
...Hezkrankheiten...
...verstorben.
Äh...
...das war's, Herr Oberz.
Äh... was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose nochmal samm gefasst?
Bei dem Patient?
Äh...
...die anamnestigen Angabe deuten am 1. äh...
...ein Lerpazirose in...
...äh...
...und äh...
...ein Hepatosegulär...
...Hepatosegulär, Karzinom in...
...mhm.
Äh... als Differenzierdiagnose...
...äh...
...kommen die äh...
...folgende äh...
...Erkrankungen äh...
...in Beispiel Portada-Trompose...
...oder...
...äh...
...Manu-Tression auch kann sein.
Aber in diesem Alter, das ist selten.
Äh... aber äh... der Patient äh...
...der Patient äh...
...erinnere äh... sich äh... einseitig äh...
...deswegen äh... kann ich auch Manu-Tression denken.
Nicht ausschließen, ja?
Ja, klar.
Gut, okay.
Alles klar.
Ähm...
...was machen Sie? Warum hat der Patient ähm...
...schmerzen beim tiefen Atmen auf der rechten Seite?
Was denken Sie?
Äh...
...wegen Lungen, würde man...
...kann sein oder ein Abscess äh...
Ach Lungen, würde man schmerzen?
Nein, aber äh...
...unterdiagnomatische äh... Abscess...
...kann sein oder äh...
Aber haben... denken Sie, ein Abscess hat ja...
...Symptome für ein Abscess.
Nein.
Hat er nicht.
Äh... aber wegen äh...
...leberkapsel äh... Schmerz kann sein.
Ja, okay. Das stimmt.
Also Sie meinen, dass es eher von der Leber kommt, der Schmerz, ne?
Ja, genau.
Ja, ja.
Gut.
Alles klar.
Was machen Sie in Untersuchung?
Bei den Patienten?
Äh... so weit...
Wir haben ja äh... in Untersuchung und Institutionen gemacht.
Und Sie haben keine Iktos vergestellt, auch in den Sklären nicht, ja?
Oder haben Sie ein Sklären-Iktos gesehen?
Äh... Ihr habt noch nicht äh... untersucht, aber äh...
Wir haben immer untersucht, vor dem Oberarzt gehen.
Wie bitte?
Wenn Sie zum Oberarzt gehen, haben Sie immer untersucht.
Oh ja, gehen Sie nicht zum Oberarzt.
Sie haben untersucht, ja?
Ah, okay. Das habe ich schon gemacht.
Ja, jetzt keinen Iktos, auch keinen Sklären-Iktos.
Okay.
Ab wann sieht man Sklären-Iktos ungefähr? Bei welchen Bidorobien wird?
Und was sieht man an Haut-Iktos ungefähr?
Äh... mehr als fünf oder zwei.
Ich verwechsel jetzt.
Also über zwei kann man Sklären-Iktos erkennen, zwei bis drei.
Und bei fünf...
Ja, ungefähr ein Haut-Iktos, richtig.
Ungefähr mal, das ist nicht immer...
Ja, genau.
Ja, aber das ist richtig, ja, okay.
Gut, was machen Sie mit den Patienten jetzt noch?
Äh... erst werde ich für Pelle unter sich hin.
Aber jetzt habe ich schon äh... gemacht.
Und äh... als Lobo-Untersuchung gehen,
werde ich äh... Blut abnehmen.
Blutbild äh...
Herr Paar, äh... Laborwerte, wie zum Beispiel äh... Albumin und äh...
Kor... Korglometrie äh...
Leverfunktionen, äh, werde ich äh... untersuchen.
Äh... PT, AP, TT, INR, äh...
Und äh... Albumin ist auch richtig.
Habt ihr gesagt, ja.
Ja.
Äh... Und Entzündungsparameter äh... CRP, BSG, äh...
Und äh...
Nierenwerte, Kreia, äh, werde ich auch untersuchen.
Äh... Urinpurbe, äh, werde ich veranlassen.
Äh... Und äh... Paracentis, werde ich durchführen.
Okay, aber Sie machen das erste Ultraschall, oder?
Gucken Sie erst mal.
Ja, natürlich, auch verschalten werden.
Wenn Sie machen, durchführen.
Okay, mmh, okay.
Gut. Und wenn Sie Paracentis machen, wie viel lassen Sie A-ab?
Äh, ich bin nicht sicher, aber es kann zehn Milliliter äh... sein.
Zehn Milliliter brauchen Sie gar nicht punktieren.
Also Sie wollen nur Diagnostisch punktieren, oder wie?
Der Patient hat so einen Bauch. So Muskeln, kleine Muskeln und so ein Bauch.
Er hat mindestens...
Therapeutische äh...
...kein Liter im Bauch.
...dass mindestens...
Wie viel Milliliter?
Fünf bis zehn Liter im Bauch.
Ja, okay.
Äh...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, dafür äh...
...möchten Sie mir etwas empfehlen?
Sie haben ja nicht gesehen, ein Patient.
Aber es ist so und hat viel...
...ja, hat viel. Also klinisch schon,
...korten Sie Asthetis bestellen.
Äh... Und Ultraschall können Sie das auch dann sehen.
Dann punktieren Sie, um wie viel lassen Sie ab bei so einen Patienten?
Den Sie jetzt gar nicht kennen.
Wenn Sie...
Wie viel äh...
Äh...
...ergust punktieren Sie ab bei der Parazynthese.
Wie viel Asthetis entlassen Sie ablaufen?
Ja, äh...
...ich habe keine Idee. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Halb Liter, ein Liter, fünf Liter, zehn Liter.
Also er hat ja Beschwerden. Also diagnostisch kann man machen.
Aber was? Einen...
Underthalb, anderthalb Liter.
Also ich hab den Patienten heute punktiert,
...habe vier und ein halb Liter auch rausgenommen.
Äh, bei den Patienten.
Aber normalerweise muss man aufpassen, ja.
Also normalerweise muss man nicht so viel ab,
...aber wenn er so wahnsinnig da unterleitet,
...kann man schon damit sich besser für das machen.
Aber ansonsten muss man auch passen,
...wenn man zu viel Asthetis entlastet auf einmal.
Was kann da passieren? Was ist die Gefahr?
Wenn Sie auf einmal...
...der Hydratation kann als Komplikation kommen.
Das kann sein, ja.
Deswegen, äh...
...nach der Medikamentöse,
...der Abilikion, für viele Leute, mehr...
...mehr...
...asthetis entnehmen.
Was kann noch passieren außer...
...der Hydratation und Kreislauf...
...qualaps oder Kreislauf?
Ja, äh...
...es kann Trombose...
...zu Trombose kommen, oder?
...wegen dieser Hydratation.
Ja, doch...
...hetzt insuffizienz kann sein.
Wenn das dann...
...wenn da ein Tarekadi bekommt, kann passieren, ja.
Mhm, genau.
Was aber kann noch passieren?
Was ist Problem bei diesen Patienten,
...leber Patienten?
Ja, äh...
...ähm...
...mhm...
...die Leber funktioniert leider nicht gut.
Deswegen äh...
...leber muss äh...
...Albumien und äh...
...sonstige Dinge äh...
...produktieren.
Aber äh...
...wenn wir alle...
...Assid...
...und alle äh...
...Flüssigkeit entnehmen...
...ehm, das ist eine Belastung für äh...
...ehm...
...leber.
Genau, Leber. Und welches Organ noch?
Was spielt der noch von?
Nähe.
Nähe, ja.
Also, die Tiere kann äh...
...accusieren, wenn...
...die Patienten ja durch...
...nehren, also die...
...und so haben die Kollegen geschrieben,
...das ist die Gefahr, wenn man zu viel ab einmal ablässt, ja.
Ja, muss man aufpassen.
Gut, äh...
...ich wollte noch irgendwas fragen, ob ich es vergessen habe,
...in dem Moment.
Ähm...
...wie ob sie...
...Nedin Astitis untersuchen.
Sie haben gesagt, was untersuchen Sie denn im Astitis?
Äh...
...Locozytin äh...
...und...
...elektrolytin...
...und Albumin in Acid, Acitis.
Bzw. Eiweiß erst mal, genau.
Ja, Eiweiß.
Warum machen Sie Eiweiß?
Was...
...was können Sie unterscheiden mit Eiweiß?
Acitis, eine Flüssigkeit?
Äh...
...deritronitis kann äh...
...mit viel Eiweiß äh...
...zeichen.
Okay.
Was nennt man, wie nennt man das, wenn es zu viel Eiweiß ist,
...im Flüssigkeit?
Lass, Citis, wie nennt man das?
Ähm...
Und wie nennt man es, wenn es zu wenig Eiweiß ist?
Äh...
...transparenz, klar und trüb.
Das ist die Beschreibung, wie es aussieht?
Ja.
Kann klar und... oder trüb sein, richtig?
Mhm.
Aber es gibt sogar zwei Klassifikationen,
...die man anhand... hauptsächlich anhand des Eiweiß...
Ja, aber jetzt kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Dann sag ich Ihnen, das eine ist Transsodat.
Ah ja, Transsodat, Exodat, ja.
Wo Eiweiß, Exodat und...
Ja, genau.
...transsodat.
Äh... wo äh...
...bei was ist äh...
...transsodats erwarten?
Bei welcher Ursache?
Ähm...
Transsodat weniger Eiweiß, meint ihr das?
Ja, wann liegt ein Transsodat vor?
Bei welcher Ursache der Acidisbildung?
Welche Krankheiten machen Transsodats?
Oder welche machen erst mal Exodat?
Machen Sie damit erst mal an.
Was liegt beim Exodat vor?
Äh... Exodat bei Äh... Infektion und...
Oh.
...vielleicht Karsino.
Ja.
Äh... Transsodat äh... bei Siros.
Siros, genau. Oder halt vorderlich richtig, genau.
Ja.
Ja, korrekt, ja.
Gut, äh... Sie haben gucken nach Leukosytton, haben Sie gesagt,
wegen Peritonitis. Und was guckt man noch nach,
wenn man schon die Zellen anguckt?
Wenn man...
Und Elektrolyte?
Kann man machen...
L, L, L, H, äh, müssen wir auch kontrollieren?
Kann man machen, aber ist nicht so wichtig.
Also vor allen Dingen wegen der Differenzialdoksenste.
Ja, ja, Zytologie.
Zytologie, genau. Tumorzellen, sage ich, ja, nein.
Genau. Korrekt.
Okay. Äh... Also Sie haben Acetes punktiert,
nicht so viel, anderthalb Liter haben Sie gemacht, ganz dampft.
Die können Sie auch mehrfach am nächsten Tag auch noch mal punktieren,
damit der Patient langsam äh... sich bessert.
Äh... Was kann man noch machen aus Acetes-Punktion?
Um die Acetes zu behandeln?
Äh... Diuretika oder äh...
Wenn Albuminwerte äh...
weniger als 1,8 Albumintransfondierend.
Ja. Richtig. Das würde ich sowieso immer...
Also machen, wenn die Acetes-Punktion machen,
also vor allem, wenn es viel machen,
würde ich dem Patienten immer Albumin-Infusionen geben danach.
Und Diuretika, und da ist vor allen Dingen...
ist es wichtig, dass bei... vor allem bei Leberzirose
oder Fortadeochto, häufig ein Hyper-Aldosterynismus vorliegt,
und dann kann man mit Alderstohnantagonisten gut arbeiten.
Ja, so ist es.
Und manchmal, also bei dem Patienten,
wenn er jetzt keine ÖD mehr im Bein hat zum Beispiel,
äh... würde ich mit Schleifendiuretika eher so ein bisschen vorsichtig sein.
Kann man machen, aber man kann erst mal mit Spirulaktoren arbeiten.
Ja.
Und wegen der Manutration, was machen Sie dann damit?
Das ist ja auch die Folge der Albuminmangel.
Was machen Sie damit?
Äh... Wir können ein Diätassistent äh...
Diätassistent konzipieren lassen.
Wir können einen Diät einlegen.
Mhm.
Ausgewogenen Diät.
Und bei schwere...
bei schwerem Fälle können wir äh...
TPN äh...
einen...
anordnen.
Was ist das TPN?
Parenteral-Nutrition können wir auch.
Ja, auch. Parenterale Ernährung, richtig.
Korrekt, ja.
Und was machen wir da? Eine ganz starke Sarkopenie.
Also hat ein massiv Muskelabbau gehabt, Sarkopenie.
Und bei dem würde ich zum Beispiel das machen, ja.
Und wenn er fragt, was soll er essen, was soll er nicht essen,
kann sie ihm was sagen.
Äh... Kochsalzarme essen ist auch wichtig.
Ja, wobei die meistens auch eine Verdünnungshyponatriemi haben.
Also Kochsalz, ja, man soll wegen der Nierenfunktion
vielleicht ein bisschen aufpassen, richtig, ja.
Aber was? Glokosearm, Glokosereich?
Kohlendrat ist viel oder wenig?
Ähm, jetzt kann ich nichts sagen.
Also vermutlich hat der ja Patienten durch die Leberzirose
auch zu wenig Glycogen-Speich in der Leber, ja.
Das heißt, er kann nicht gegenreagieren.
So dass man da vermutlich den Patienten
erst mal doch Kohlendrat- äh...
reicher Ernährung auch geben würde.
Mhm.
Und bei dem Muskelabbau ist es immer gut,
wenn man den auch Proteinreich ernährt,
dann müssen sie halt aufpassen bei der Leberfunktion, ja.
Und die Nierenfunktion auch.
Nierenfunktion auch, aber Hauptsache die Leberfunktion.
Aber wenn der jetzt keine Leber-Synthese-Störung hat,
wenn es eine Leberzirose, Child A ist zum Beispiel,
dann ist es kein Problem, können Sie auch Proteinreich ernähren.
Ja.
Würde ich bei den Patienten auch machen.
Kennen Sie die Child-Klassifikation?
Child-Klassifikation bei Leberzirose, jetzt ABC.
Ihr habt schon mal gehört dabei, jetzt kann ich...
Ich muss auch mal nachgucken, spielt immer Rolle.
Astitis ja, nein.
Albumin im Serum, Bibliorubin hat er zum Beispiel nicht gehabt.
Äh, dann Encephalopathy.
Ja, das wirken Trimo.
Äh, Asthythalopathy kann man mit Trimo auch beschreiben.
Äh, der Quick-Wert, also Geringon, Coagulation.
Und das war's, glaub ich, sind, glaub ich,
fünf items, glaub ich.
Dann kann man einen Score machen, dann kann man nachlesen, ABC.
Bünstigstens C haben ganz schlechte Prognose, ja.
Child C, ja.
Gut, alles klar.
Gibts dazu noch Kommentare oder weitere Fragen?
Haben wir eigentlich das Wichtigste besprochen, ja?
Mhm.
Ist oberste Frieden, oberste Frieden?
Also Dr. Ailes hat es gut gemacht.
Ja, gut gemacht.
Und konnte auch auf die Fragen immer gut antworten, das ist wichtig.
Dass man so im Gespräch bleibt.
Gegenfragen stellen und so war das gut.
Sehr gut.
Danke.
Äh, Epikris.
Soll ich jetzt kurz vorstellen, ja?
Ja.
So wie ich's hören würde gerne, ja?
Ich, ich, äh, ich, äh,
ich, äh, hier ist der Patient,
der hat eine Schischklinik, der sich sagt,
Ja, hanım söylü, dedi,
Çok hz nefesalıyorum, dedi.
Hanım, hanım söylü, deshka, hanum ma, she, hanum ma bakmjaksın.
Hanum sadece, quats altmüch, oldunu söylemüch kendisinde.
Hani hz, hz nefesal adunu söylemüch, kendisi hissetmüyo mesela.
Nakhchivaisi yerine, Hiperhydroziz,
Stelke, Hiperhydroziz, ehh, diebidiür miis?
Ainesi deil, olmadı icin, benden nahtchivaisi takalim.
Ehh, Hiperhydroziz demie temi elim mi,
Patrychik ehh, demie elim,
ein 58-jähriger Patient in reduziertem Allgemeinzustand und noch normalem Ernährungszustand in dem Fall.
Der Patient stellt sich vor mit einer starken körperlichen Schwäche, die seit einer Corona-Infektion vor etwa 2-3 Monaten
sich zunehmend ausgeprägt hat und sich verstechtert hat.
Und der Patient angibt seit dieser Zeit in den letzten Monaten ca. 10 kg Gewicht verloren zu haben.
Der Patient ist so schwach, dass er kaum den Weg zur Toilette schafft, hat in der letzten Zeit gemerkt,
dass er neben den massiven Muskelauchbau aber Abbau eine deutliche Vermehrung des Bauchumfangs bemerkt hat
und auch dort in diesem Bereich auch Beschwerden grenzwertige Schmerzen angibt,
weswegen er vom Haushalts auch schon Schmerzmedikamente bekommen hat.
Der Patient berichtet, dass er kaum Appetit hat, wenig essen kann und dass er fast regelmäßig, fast täglich erbrechen müsse.
Bei dem Erbrochenen berichtet der Patient über gallikgelbliche Erbrechten,
jedoch wird vom Patienten eine Hemmatemesis verneint.
Der Patient berichtet auch weiterhin, dass er bei tiefer Inspiration Schmerz in der rechten Flanke im Bereich des rechten Oberbaus hat.
Die Artennot ist fremdbeinnahmennäßig von der Frau berichtet worden.
Der Patient selbst merkt an der Kurzartigkeit nichts.
An Vorerkrankten berichtet der Patient an einer chronischen Hepatitis B zu leiten, weswegen er auch an die mirostatische Therapie bekommt.
Des Weiteren nimmt der Medikamente ein bei bestehender arterieller Hypatonie und einer Hypotheriose.
Vom Haushalts hat der Patient in letzter Zeit wegen der Beschwerden Novalgene und Tramadolol erhalten.
Die restliche Anamnese ist bis auf eine familiäre Patitis B-Infektion nicht richtungsweisend.
Die klinischen Befunde deuten am ehesten darauf hin, dass der Patient mit einer Acetes-Bildung zu uns kommt,
wobei hier als Ursache entweder eine dekumbensierte Leberzirose vorliegen könnte, wobei sonstige Zirosezeichen hier nicht im Vordergrund stehen,
vor allen Dingen keine Bilirubin-Erhöhung, keinen Ektorus und auch keine Encephalopathy und Blutungszeichen.
Wir kommen am ehesten weiter durch eine Laboruntersuchung und Sonografischuntersuchung mit der Frage auch nach anderen Ursachen
von einer Portalipertension, zum Beispiel Fort Adatromose.
Für die weitere Therapie würde ich nach der Ultraschalluntersuchung, falls Acidis nachweisbar wäre,
eine Acidisparanthesitese durchführen zu weiteren Diagnostiken und auch zur Entlastung.
Des Weiteren würden wir gerne den Patienten unseren Ernährungstherapeuten vorstellen, um die sicherlich begleitende Malotration zu behandeln,
eventuell auch durch eine parentale Ernährung.
Das wäre es ganz schnell gemacht, aber das Wichtigste für den Oberarzt, glaube ich.
Das ist sehr gut.
Habt Ihr Kollegen noch Fragen?
Ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel weggelassen, dass das Familiengeschichte oder was er gearbeitet hat.
Das müssen Sie fragen, sollten Sie auch fragen bei einer Mese, aber bei der Vorstellung vom Oberarzt
ist es jetzt nicht wichtig, ob er selbstständig ist oder rentner ist.
Ich kann Situationen geben, wo es wichtig ist, aber in dem Fall eher nicht,
wegen dem Oberarzt mit solchen Informationen nicht belasten und auch nicht mit,
wann der Vater gestorben ist, weswegen der Vater gestorben ist,
wenn es jetzt für diese aktuelle Problematik nicht so relevant ist.